[Music]
you do the intro and I'm just going to
switch into all the Roxy different
seating positions the entire time you
ready I'm
ready are you comfortable I'm very
comfortable hey Greg know something I'd
never do to you what unfriend you oh
that's so sweet of
you okay now you're unfriended today
we're watching unfriended which is a
movie I have been sworn not to Google so
I don't know a sing actor in this I
don't know a director for all I know
it's a reality movie Greg what do you
know about unfriended I know that uh
it's a horror movie and supposedly it's
a lot of fun how do you stay still I
don't understand how one would stay
still you know what from now on I'm
doing my intro room over here at least I
wear cool socks for you how do you think
this intro is going to go do you think
people are going to like this intro I do
okay and I think that they should let us
know by leaving a like comment
subscribing hit that notification if you
want to see all of this which you should
you're our fulllength Reaction watch
along where you sync up with your own
copy is available on patreon all the
sexy people don't let their feet Hit the
Floor this we know oh oh you let your
feet Hit the Floor my dude you have to
say Purge when you hit if you're over on
patreon Greg and John C for several
shows over there exclusively reaction
highlights and watch alongs included I
think I'm just going to ask you uh a
question every 5 minutes for the
remainder of this movie to see if you
know what's happening or what's going
Happ in the entire time you know that
all the people at home that like me or
the people who don't like me want to get
rid of me they have no power you have
all the power and yet you still choose
to have me here that's right who's the
winner see I complimented you with the
me so I'm never going to unfriend you
what' you do I am paying you the biggest
flattery compliment I I am flattered I
am impersonating that YouTube intro was
two and a half was that my fault okay
for the entire reaction however I'm
sitting every time you have to sit oh
dude I can do that all right Greg what
what are you going to do without your
heart chair I can I can get comfortable
yeah no this is good so uh we'll see you
guys on the other side of what is short
to
be three
two
one huh
[__] you're at a disadvantage the
armchairs I have no arms I mean I do
have
arms you're doing very well you
does
oh what is happening maybe it's part of
the movie I hope so is this found
footage
movie uh something with the
internet mhm did you see that I'm on my
tiptoes this is a horrible
agreement
oh wa this looks so
weird
whoa oh damn this is a serious subject
matter Live
[Music]
Leak maybe I won't joke around as
much immediately gives me um who are
those Brothers in the forest Vibes the
Logan Pauls yes the loan Pauls what's on
her arm she's holding something that I
think she's going to use on herself
[Music]
wow and I told Roxy beforehand that
we're going to try to watch a
fun what [__] the video that Forester
was online here they said she going to
beat my ass
everybody oh my
[Music]
god oh this is disturbing as
hell hey hey baby what's up you okay
that's the guy from the video right I
got something to show you doing your
demon voice again you like them yeah oh
that's so hot getting me there and feet
too I love just the top of
toes what wait you don't like them do
you are you a feed person I'm not really
a feed person they don't gross me out
they're fine you know what you just let
me come over and show you how it's done
my dad would kill you fine that's worth
it I for you she was just watching that
video and then immediately moved on to
this take that shirt off before I cut it
off that's really violent take the shirt
off or I'll cut it off such a weird back
and forth where did he grab the knife
from I guess he has a knife you're
adorable and really sexy when you're
violent uh that can be a very
regrettable statement red flag times a
million why do you have a little speech
planned
I
stop what I want to make prom night the
night oh damn they're high schoolers
they talk like high schoolers they look
like high schoolers that's great that
is that's finally the reaction I was
looking 2 4 68 we appreciate
mov I wonder how they filmed this it
seems like they were probably really
just filmed it this
way hey we'll call him back yeah yeah
yeah get the knife baby let's see man
she's really confident for someone who
hasn't God oh my God oh no God little
someone's in there CH that was really
well edited the way they did
that what's up hey guys where you coming
from
man hey guys K BL how are you you're
blouse babe what
what are you calling my Dr babe for what
who's your
buddy that's not what kind of you
guys this is just awesome I try to hang
up on this thing it wouldn't let me you
take turns this honestly was not in with
us that came with you guys it's not
working damn what a creepy setup for a
stalker totally the usage of Skype here
is really smart their back yeah
bye
bye holy [__] this is just one big
screen recording
yeah oh whoever that person is let it
happen what happened to
Mitch oh my God I used to type like that
I remember really thinking was cute the
more letters you used at the end of a
word where are you he is super fuing
natural not
Supernatural natural now I get what
you're saying cuz you clarify why isn't
he picking up was he
killed obviously he's not there bro I
mean it said the video trying to watch
my words made her unive herself at the
beginning are they experiencing
something that is
otherworldly
pick
up his icon other thing it's definitely
a hacker he's spying to get info on
farts and boners okay is that what
today's agenda is well we haven't hit
the farts yet but I didn't realized it
was just going to be essentially a
singular shot but like a clever way of
making it feel like one long take so why
when she's messaging him is it really
going to the ghost
dude uh must be some type of hacker her
situation yeah but he hacked into
Mitch's thing so she
not should it be from
whom Laura bar oh it's one from the
beginning and remember she's the girl
from the video of why Laura Barnes un
alived herself
yeah oh
wow old
Facebook
okay you need a question mark in there
somewhere babe but it's got to represent
that she's a high
schooler oh the suspense of the
typing why
could why could we hear the typing it
it's kind of like a feedback thing
yeah maybe what do you mean
maybe what's up
so were you guys really siming no is
that like a thing you do it's huh it's
really cute damn this guy really is in
her yo so I talked to Kyle about Friday
and I got the weed but he's out of Molly
so this really does feel authentic
yeah do you think that that's actually
Mitch here my here my question
big
2012 what a fascinating experience to
create this movie you got to create a
whole bunch of graphics and [__] and
just time everything out I'm looking for
like hidden
Cuts why can't we hear them uh I think
that is the movies editor Choice get us
to focus
okay so she died in 2013 it's the year
anniversary so it's April 12th 2014
right now they're not questioning at all
why she's just being super quiet looking
into all
this that's what I kind of mean by the
like the volumes down
Purge let not explain it for anyone who
did not watch The Purge
reaction that's they're
bad
I got her I got her I got her I feel
like we can solve this this movie's
mystery only by asking the right
question yeah and that's where you come
in
really don't need is shorten the words
seriously they must have just gotten
like hours and hours of footage of these
people just like laughing responding
whatever yeah I wonder if it's like an
improvised movie yeah
totally
unfriend you can't unfriend oh what a
nightmare that would be yeah not even
without this scenario but if you just
didn't have the ability to unfriend or
unfollow someone you could be more
helpful babe refresh the page did you
blow on
it I'm not trying to be funny right now
I honestly think this editor deserved an
Oscar this is like crazy it worked but
the movie's called unfriended was that
the
mistake
come shouldn't have unfriended for like
a second are you talking to boys hey I'm
writing an email
stop oh that was your mistake you
shouldn't have done
that all right never mind I'm not going
to unfriend anyone just going to mute
your
post
she said what do you want but already
she typed I want your help you think she
can see her right now
yes it's a good
point which one's Val vond girl I'm
assuming guys did you talk to Val
tonight Oh's when we were at Adam party
she was I'm can I just be honest I don't
like Val nobody likes Val don't say that
hey
Val Val turn up the sound you dumb
[__]
can you hear me now K yeah there you are
you Floy hi yeah you know when you talk
and it's muted I can still hear you on
your end so I don't appreciate dumb
[__] yeah these actors are good you
said you were going to get them no you
didn't no I told you to buy them so now
I'm hearing that you guys are going to
be seated in the balcony testing her so
maybe you should buy ticket sooner like
I told you a care that's too bad I wish
you bought your ticket early what a
clever way to provide a soundtrack for
the Val what looking good thank
you uh I don't think Val knows about
these posts no check your
Facebook
what oh my God this is like a horror
movie about hacking why would you post
that this the first time I'm seeing
these These are Incredible God it just
came from your account I've never seen
these before these are amazing I didn't
know you were so much fun oh my god oh
this is embarrassing I didn't do this
okay I don't know why you're getting so
oh my God you trashy little [__] delete
them wait wait did you just call me
trashy are you serious Jeff oh no oh no
yeah I didn't do it okay so you can you
can be nice to me and I can help you or
you can
suck and piss off the cross talk and
everything real so
real oh my God this is so
funny wa was that like a I don't know
I'm reading too much I know the glitches
and stuff look I'll come pick you girls
up and we can go fight outside of a
Wendy's or something
okay you can go to a Taco Bell parking
lot and you guys can slap fight it out
I'll pick both of you up we have to look
up how this movie was made yeah yeah the
dialogue sounds very natural and
everyone's personalities are distinct
they all feel like they know each other
really
well [__] what you posted some now too
but did you just like copy and paste
those
post
anything I'm a [__] really dude I'm not
even typing I don't know what to say
what is happening right now okay I dated
like two guys I didn't type you okay oh
my God this is so creepy I didn't
stop D okay yeah just you think it's
just like a hacker situation so much
let's oh Blair you're just going to take
Jess's side I'm not on Jess's side she
called it the wrong name so it must be
improv stuff too no I didn't type you
didn't type it then who
did they're they're presenting
themselves well who the is Billy I told
you I didn't post those photos about
guys who is this I don't know here the
whole time Ken you said it was just a
glitch why would Ken
now guess
who bruer dude I bet this guy's been
here the whole time I do not know B but
he apparent
barns ah so some one of them must be
held accountable for what happened to
Laura
yeah it is so uncomfortable it's like
your brother or something why would he
do that Jess he was a weird isn't you
not that
weird why would he be messing with
you he did do that weird knife
thing
it's probably just like a troll or
something what is a
troll like someone that just harasses
people online that was it a new term
that that was for people who who aren't
online and like the adults watching in
the theater at what is a troll Universal
was like they need to explain what a
troll is for the
audience if you don't take these down
right now I'll come over there and knock
the trash out of your
ears who the is this guy why do you
assume it's a guy yeah don't be sexist
okay you wouldn't like all right let's
stop [__] around everyone hands up
right now who's doing this not me Adam
here we go he said not
me I'm I'm for uh fake fake that girl I
I love it I love this character there's
no button to hang up
on
it's like is it the ghost or is it just
someone ex extracting Revenge well
there's no way it's the ghost you don't
know that where did you get this this is
up you hear me calm down Val no I can't
calm down what is it what did they send
her really that's a threat yeah I you
know what yes good news I'm calling the
cops congratulations
[__] why is Jess laughing because
they all hate B Ken I swear to God if I
find out this is you I will burn you
alive you
understand thanks for stopping by Val
real nice lady real nice
chick she said she was going to burn me
alive
dude sorry she takes a [__] screen grabs
of the stuff that he was saying whoa
whenever they best with their faces it
really feels
disconcerting come over Adam and we'll
go see uh Kyle we'll go across the
tracks Val plays the game I just got an
email from him what is it it's a link
just a stupid troll dude obvious troll
is obvious I love how that one dude just
seems so apathetic no foring button it's
at the bottom if you click on like reply
all I I know where it is but yeah oh my
God Blair do you know how to use a
computer open it he's not apathetic now
no no no character trajectory just
forward this [__] on to Ken so we don't
have to deal with this don't share your
screen babe until you know what it is
see look oh my God it literally doesn't
exist there's no forward button do you
see it
no oh no dude weird computer [__]
happens to me all the time I'm scared
she's going to click on it everybody's
watching no no no no no no don't do it
open it don't do it don't do it why
won't you do that click the link dude
yeah I'm right there with you
man hey oh that V told Laura in V's
defense your comment wasn't completely
unwarranted okay nobody wants to talk
about it but I'll give you the Ken
pinion Laura sucks she was a big bully
okay and she deserved all the [__] she
got from that video oh damn dude I don't
get what the video was I need to watch
see the end the rest of it
yeah oh people didn't like Laura huh oh
no
hello you're all so brave with your
secret
profiles come laugh at my
face you sorry seaw
wordss you didn't know her like me
interesting okay let us see the video
it's having loading issues no it's
playing we hear the
music uh oh some traumatizing stuff
happen is she still sharing her screen
maybe she
stopped neat way to hint
[Music]
at your screen's being watched maybe
she's lur maybe she has a split
personality
and she's his
account
oh moner
exposure it is super messed up to tell
somebody to themselves yeah I've had
that happen many times sure you have to
and like people just do it and they
don't think that they are repercussions
and like and people have acted on that
by being told that creeper what do you
want is she going to do it she's going
to do it she cop oh no it's a
bleach I think it's frozen oh we're
going to get a glitch experience of it
oh my God hey Val you stupid [__] say
something uh now is not the time to
tease that Billy wrote I don't know when
she did why did Billy write
that oh my God I just got to like cut to
her being dead isn't it yeah totally
look at her
mirror you guys see the Mirror
Mirror she going over there oh that's
great right there and behind her on her
left what about it it's not a glitch
it's all shattered oh but it looked like
a glitch on the screen look look at it
it's right
there oh oh she's not oh she's froz
she's not frozen
wow that is so creepy that is so creepy
man what was that holy [__] [__] we've
seen some
trance like what we saw with the other
girl Laura the hell looking at her arm
what just
happened did it
drop we going to see blood just start to
drip on the floor
hello hello hey the
dog oh she called the cops earlier
remember yeah hey hello can you hear us
wait what' they say
10:35 10:30
what is that
10:35 uh 5250 5250 I didn't hear 5250
it's a mental
C oh [__] B used to have seizures she
had the sickness that causes seizures
epilepsy freaking seizure seen her have
a seizure
ever told you this in an email 1055 1055
1055 is
yesh foul oh my my
God you think the police would want to
be like maybe they can't hear for some
reason I don't know oh my god oh man you
all judge
Laura there here is one of yours not
boyfriend did she cheat I'm tempted I
want to see yeah me too I would open
it he's definitely going to open it
right oh my God 12 seconds 11 seconds
this is like a ticking Time Bomb
what who are
you oh my God oh my God she's cheating
on him with his best friend that's why
he was so into her yeah babe why' you
call my girlfriend babe then you guys
what she created memes out of it we we
got to get him out who cares we have to
go over and help B okay we can do this
[__] after wait wait hold on the the
cops are with the cops are
with who saw that who saw that I think
just her
dude I want to play a game want to play
a game oh and she was even holding out
we don't know that she was holding out
for Mitch we don't know for prom We
don't know that she wasn't sleeping with
the other guy I know it seems that she
was guys can you just trust me okay
install this program and I'll find out
who it is K can get him out okay we need
to stop this guy you guys want to know
who this is damn is that clock at the
top p in real time what is it uh it's
just a game we're just all going to
download it and play it right I guess
you like games you seem to like games
dude I thought we were going to play I I
great game for you man I mean obviously
Billy's going to choose the
game I got something for you
Billy okay okay okay is it is it
searching guys yo what's this guy doing
he's got I don't know is it flagging has
everybody got some Flags it should be
more than one too it should be multiple
okay stop okay hit trash what is he
getting I have no clue delete listen to
me trust me dude why'd you stop [__]
okay where is gun did you see that I'm
having a hard time knowing where to look
I'm just watching why is she okay chess
mine's done okay she
didn't there's a lot in my recycling bin
I I don't know how to make it go why
does he have a gun he going to be cool I
promise
there's a pen wheel I don't what is this
game no it's not a game he's trying to
help them
oh it's done done it's done it's gone
yes is it gone is he out thank you
Ken Adam you pulled out got Adam you did
pull out it that thing oh no you were it
around it's going to go off I can't
believe it we going to shoot what we
going to do is shoot through the
computer
is she the
computer Val used to get seizures and I
mean that's the only thing I can think
of okay I mean but you heard what the
report
was I don't think have they okay I think
it's been hacked now now do you think
you think Mitch has been hacked
yeah there's the
house there the house oh my God it's
interesting they're doing this all from
her
perspective oh never mind maybe they are
together
herh I'm a little anxious me too and
they also threatened our friend Valley
RL you sent some officers over there
earlier to our house oh damn after what
that Val thing happened are you right
now sir um I'm home are you safe yeah
all of
you yeah we're good seems like an
ominous call
yeah don't hang
up who did you
call it's his
ass I'm back did you just say that
yeah
whose room are they
in everyone move around yeah wave your
hands so you could
identify
oh wait
k damn wait come back what back up a
little bit why just do it dude dude you
could piece it together yourself
Ken oh my God
oh my God
Greg it's G to be okay
Roxy Ken's totally
dead I got
it oh my
God I wonder if they all have like a
hidden camera in their
room this is such Innovative film making
dude Ken what the going
on oh no there is like a rumbling sound
design though that is an audition not
part of it's like how she can't hear
them when she this is all like from her
perspective why don't you try calling
Billy that be my first order of
business oh no is just a
one-on-one Ken is that shattered glass
behind him or a glitch don't
know Ken
Ken Ken oh my God what is
happening
Ken
[Music]
whoa holy [__] oh my God happened that
got like extremely violent out of
nowhere his hand in a blunder right yeah
ow Get Your Gun again are they all where
was the knock whose door had the knock
just
now [__] oh no it's yeah got to be
something Supernatural that's
happening I think it is they're getting
possessed
somehow have you seen the ring yeah but
not for years kind of like what Sam
imagine what's happening like through
the screen some type of exposure to yeah
that's kind of what it said in that
Forum you
see Adam Adam what do you
see it's like a
virus there's [__] no one
here fix your camera angle who's
here I a god you hear me oh no he's
going to shoot him he that is my concern
damn the guy wielding the gun is she's
so upset because she also hooks up with
him I know I feel bad for
her what do you
want want to take out the trash yo I'm
team Billy
227 what
video you be my ass going to beat my ass
every that's Laura right
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah oh when force quit doesn't even
help
yeah well what's the situation
there I think they're trying to say that
she [__]
herself
oh did he take the
video but it
was fake
accounts you must confess
whoa whoa interesting
okay she's going to publicize this right
oh man that's humiliating what happened
to
Laura oh my god let's find
out what's the
game it's a drinking
game for the adults in the audience
yeah okay let's play wait how do you
play how do you play I'm playing your
[__] game I can play I'll win
Somebody explain the rules to Blair okay
you put up five fingers and then if
you've done something you have to put
your finger down Craig you have to be
honest about this all right okay put it
in put them up that's how it works but
in this version the loser doesn't drink
what do they do they
die yeah that's right they did explain
that yeah pay
attention ever started the rumor that
Blair has an eating dis I have never
done that he didn't do it wasn't me 10 n
okay it was me okay okay I you said it
was Val Okay I lied all
right it's not like there's not some
kind of Truth in there what are you
doing
dude I'm not hungry I already ate all
that [__] wow oh dude I'm team
Billy Crash J as mother's it wasn't me I
don't think this game has been for a
universal audience Roxy I didn't do it
sorry it was me okay we were drunk and
it happened great friend Blair I have
apologized she has not apologized for
starting this rumor thing about me we're
keeping together on
this made out with Laura Barnes did you
Laur easy who said last year she kissed
me I threw her off nothing happened
that's
fine sold out Adam to the cops for
selling weed I didn't do
that it was me man hey it was me it was
you yeah dude what why at least he's
Zing up really fast I hope he survives I
almost had a record my d Almost dis me
for that dude it was going to be both of
us or one of us and I would do the same
[__] for you it doesn't matter what's
the last one we're doing well I know
we're AC this
game no I didn't steal
$800 oh
man okay oh keep it
[__] what happened to formal he was
drunk I got bit by a bug Greg what I
don't know I can feel I just got a bug
bite
really maybe it's the movie wa what did
that one just say just what did it say
trade life I don't
know Craig I was you were saying you got
a bug F I was
distracted have ever ever what Jess's
life she always tells the truth to Pi up
what they saying you always tell the
truth right Blair know that he hooked up
tell the truth we know that they hooked
up but that wasn't what they
said put it down put it down Blair if it
was you put it down fine it was
me offered to trade Jess's Life For
Mine I hate you I hate you I hate you
you guys are all perfect
righte guys guys guys on come on come on
you're getting it or no I'm Miss well
I'm missing some offered to trade Jess's
life for the three of yours so Billy
messaged Adam and said will you trade
Jess's life for all of yours and he said
yes okay yeah Never Have I Ever Had
Sex You we get a timer please he's
making it so that she has to put her
finger down hey Billy uh why is the
timer still going huh what are you doing
Tock the round ain't over doing oh God
put it down put it down I'm
sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry never have I
ever what are you doing my boyfriend's
best what are you doing oh my God is he
serious I'm so sorry he serious he the
Adam it was an
accident his fell into me stop talking
Adam stop it it doesn't matter remember
Mitch it
doesn't
guys that's a you
it's that's
amazing love it great use of Music in
this movie that it's so funny never have
I ever Ashley
D
Jesus oh look at
that that's how you you guys are the
worst we forgot to keep playing did you
Ashley Dane no no no no did you your
boyfriend best friend no okay yeah I'm
still good M I love you
perfect you don't even know it only
lasted like a second oh [__]
[Music]
you never have I ever forced Ashley Dane
to get in a stop doing this guys I'm
sorry okay everybody
just Adam you deserve
this
wasn't
oh my God why are you showing this oh
this is really don't watch just don't
watch okay not he recorded it that's
remember he started with do you remember
the video yeah we've switched roles
today I'm asking all the
[Laughter]
questions I am I am okay let's go let's
go I'm right we killing this
game
F I love the glitches it it does feel
like after he's about to kill himself oh
no it feels like ghostly when it
happens what what what is it says I'm
not supposed to tell you what it says
tell us right now you piece of [__]
you're never going to find out okay so
get your narrow F head around that you
hear me Jess is just chilling say I
can't Adam and Blair with
another like that you don't understand
okay just calm down okay everybody just
calm down this has no right to be this
good yeah is gripping it I'm soed this
is so gri part of his kind of like a CW
drama but
then we met up one more one more time to
see if it was a fluke or something
more was at my house you shut up let me
talk to him let me talk to they met him
again did he touch you again did he
touch you again down
there just for a second okay just for a
second oh man that would destroy me if
they did it twice yeah have you ever
been cheated on it's horrible yes it's a
horrible feeling my high school
boyfriend cheated on me with my 14 best
friends had sex with every one of them
you're
[Laughter]
[Music]
La no oh my God no oh
damn
damn so it just happens like unwillingly
so she revealed it so Mitch Wouldn't Die
yeah free life cams are the absolute
best having beautiful women all over the
Internet just waiting to fulfill your
every desire there's simply nothing I'm
not going to oh my God that was her yeah
that's what I was telling
you I didn't do anything J do not answer
do not give in
what whatever you do do not
answer I got Jess J just run just just
run I'm going to get you
help
what why go to chat
roulette yes okay hi guys look at me hey
look at me hi she needs me to call the
cops something is happening something
can I happening and it's happening right
now
4478 there's this girl and she's online
and she says that there's someone
attacking her she's in Fresno California
what what's the address yeah done sting
it to you right now sorry 1 minute is it
deleting yeah they said they're 5
minutes away 5 minutes okay okay okay
Jess there's a car coming the cops are
coming they're going to be there in five
minutes that was actually smart thinking
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter
the cops to coming oh my god Jess Jess
Jess just just run it looks okay if
self-inflicted right so but if the cops
got there in time they could restrain
you or something I don't
[Applause]
know oh
no oh my God her curling iron
oh my God that's the most painful thing
I've ever seen in my entire
life oh my
God jeez oh my
God how do you stop
this I mean you have to admit what you
did maybe it but they did didn't they
she texted it maybe he didn't I don't
know maybe they didn't say it out loud
or clear enough or enough I mean this
guy doesn't seem like he's got too much
baggage it's going to be okay guys blue
you're going to make it to prom no I
don't think that's true I think they
deserve a go to prom together they
deserve a good prom really I think he
deserves much
better it's it's an alarm I said for
tomorrow we have a test why is she
[Music]
smiling do you hate me oh my God
I don't hate you but you don't no I
don't hate you I love you so much I love
you you're a good guy oh no he did
something
horrible that wasn't us Laura no it was
him Mitch did
it Laura I promise
you
oh that's his big secret He Ain't So
Soft he ain't so good he ain't so good
she's having a hard
time dude what's the harm in just
admitting it right now just admit it
you're gon to die I think he's gonna die
huh if he admits it he's going to die
will he die if he admits it I think so
based on like all the other things that
other people admitted I thought the
whole point is to confess yeah but then
the loser dies if your hands go down
first you die you lose you know you
don't drink I thought you lose if all
your hands go down right so I think that
that's what she's trying to
do say it go back to his face I want to
see him it was him
[Music]
yep
jesz remember the knife yeah wait
no came back around okay
Katy guys I'm so sorry why did you
[Music]
do to way to go Laura
what's the countdown
for what do you think I
did did you unfriend Laura
Barnes vengeful
Spirit got her she didn't post it but
she recorded
it oh now you got to live with it or
she's just going to
die
whoa whoa what the hell so that was her
ghost wow
myth oh damn there a Blum House
I was just thinking they know they know
what they're doing man what was the
budget on that that was Unreal $100 how
that was so good actually written huh
damn that was crazy what' you say that
was actually
written like I want to know how it was
written I don't know that was wild you
know before you showed up how unsharp
I've been today but have you been
unfriended no no man wow I cannot get
over that movie I know well it's only
been like 5 seconds so maybe give us
some time and you might get over it soon
okay cool let me just sit here and try
to get over it sure thing buddy let me
just chill for a minute while I try to
get over it I got to look
up was the
movie
unfriended
improvised cast friend was given a basic
outline of the story and improvise their
dialogue throughout the entire filming
process
wow so there okay yeah that's CRA it
seem that way there's no way it was shot
on one take no no no
no
um fil 10 horror movies filmed in one
continuous shot let's see whoa what one
of the actors requested they shoot the
entire film at once so they set up
multiple rooms for all the actors in
their own room on a computer acting out
in the
film damn Which actor what have they
done since this was so
interesting yeah man that was that was
well worthwhile do what did you think
about the very
ending that it is some kind of Laura
Barn figure who's killing
them yeah know I mean I figured it was a
supernatural entity the whole time so
you like ending yeah I mean didn't you
figure it was a supernatural entity yeah
but that's not my question just what do
you think of the
ending you like that that she didn't she
didn't make it out that the Laura Barnes
type figure came Oh Oh you mean like the
of what happened to her yeah just cuz
you had been saying like oh she's got to
live with herself I would I would have
preferred um something that was a little
bit more open ended in that regard of
like oh will she continue to live or
will
she through social and stuff will she go
down the same path as what Laura of the
of the actions that Laura took really
trying to watch my words here taking the
actions that Laura took I would have
preferred that instead of cutting to
into uh Laura I mean I I still I liked
it in the in the in the moment in the
moment it's spooky um cuz I prefer when
it was just a screen recording instead
of switching to oh now we're actually in
her physical POV instead of looking like
we're watching a screen recording yeah
will you look at the budget for me dude
whatever you
want it's the only thing um I'm I'm I'm
with you I felt like because I sometimes
living with the consequences of your own
actions million dooll budget damn I
thought they would made for even less
than that gross 32.5 mil damn that's a
$32.5 million profit
mhm that's really good that's very
impressive man worldwide gross of 64
million so that's way bigger C63 million
profit cuz this came up before searching
and before missing uh before searching
and before missing and searching and
missing are like the super Advanced
version of something like this you know
what I mean um net profit 17.1 mil they
must have been stoked with this I mean
really good I thought the actors are so
natural in this I mean yeah the Improv
really does help but you were talking
about the ending yeah I just want to
know your thoughts but what are your
thoughts I said yeah same as you that's
exactly how I felt yeah yeah on the same
page we just were like I was saying
about the consequences of your own
action like living with that I think is
like a little spookier than her also
biting the dust yeah but I what it's not
a big deal it wasn't like oh the ending
ruined it for me I just know that you
had been like oh now she's to live with
it and I was thinking the same thing and
I was like uh yeah I think it could have
been like she leaves and then it just
goes to Black yeah totally and then it's
like oh what she going to do cuz we see
all the comments start scrolling in and
they're telling her go un alive yourself
and all of that wow that was really good
did you have a for lack of better words
favorite
character um was there one that you
liked the best not like was the best
person but one that you were drawn to to
the most no I really like Blair I did
yeah Blair was good it's funny how she I
I love how they just all become horrible
throughout the course of the movie
they've all done horrible things they
just unveil how terrible it is it's a
cautionary tale about like cyber
bullying as well yeah like what seems
normal when it's around you you know
like even like Jess making up the eating
disorder situation and it's just like
that's the kind of stuff that actually
happens in high school yeah people
spread rumors like that and then you
don't know how far you're like what the
lies that you make up how far that could
affect somebody else's life who were
your favorite characters I think that I
I did really like them all I really
liked mitchie's character yeah because I
think that like you towards the end is
just like but what has he done and you
know it's got to be something you know
that this is targeted and the fact that
like even he who got cheated on and like
you know all those horrible things that
he was hearing about and you're feeling
bad for him but then it's like he posted
this video and it ruined her life and
what was what was really crazy about how
they did this movie is like they get you
to buy into it's not your like your
typical type of script whatsoever of
like what is their backstory establish
their motivations and goals and why and
all these things you know it's just this
A Tale of they're they're trapped in a
Skype nightmare situation and they have
to survive the night and the go goal is
to get to the truth right uh it seems
like there no there's no way they would
have really gotten out of the situation
seems like regardless right B off the
rules of the game yeah um and and I but
what I loved about it was how they do
get you invested in these guys just via
their personality they don't there's no
like save the cat moment or some [__]
like that that that they just feel so
genuine and their personalities feel so
relatable and likable or not even
relatable but just authentic
that that's what gets you invested in
them even to the point where when they
are unveiling like how horrible they are
you don't actually suspect that they're
all terrible they've all done something
truly terrible but it lines up you know
if they're not treated like this big
revelation of just this Terri some some
moments are like but all every terrible
thing they did lines up and it's just
well it's a well structured film by way
the the enalion go like it's it's really
well spaced out yeah I was thinking that
too like when Val first dies is the
timing of that is good versus when it's
Ken ver you know like everything I think
they hit their marks when they needed to
so that you were invested the whole time
it's a short movie obviously but they
could have waited towards the end to
start all of like uh picking them off
one by one but the fact that it was like
a slower
burn I mean um that we had one earlier
on and then we had to wait cuz we know
them what they're capable of because we
know what they did to Val and even that
kind of like still in your mind like was
it a seizure it didn't seem like that
yeah but then them still thinking it
might not be what we believe it to be
until we see blender
gate yeah what was your what did you
think was the for lack of better words
coolest of the unal
livings so there's the gun there's the
knife there's the blender there's the
curling iron in the mouth I think the
most inventive one is a curling iron in
the mouth but that shock value of the
blender moment is
cuz it because it's suddenly so violent
yeah like the the opening moment is
disturbing just due to the context and
yeah the visual of it but it's not like
horror movie explosive Gore in any
capacity my my favor was Val just
completely Frozen and that was really
creative starting to move that was
extremely creative I I thought that was
interesting as our our first major one
and the usage the glass and the
glitching and stuff really cool yeah I
really dug that I'm looking right now
has 62% on Rotten Tomatoes and 5.6 on
IMDb I think that's low it's hor
horror especially in this category we
kind of talked about it with like As
Above So Below Horror in this category
egregiously low yeah like it's just one
of those like this this movie has a fan
base for a
reason um you ignore that okay we had
this thing pop up this is there's
insufficient disc face between recording
and and he could see me be like yeah and
and because of that it also kind of felt
like the movie for a second like we're
getting some message totally what do you
think unfriended dark web could
be uh friends messing around on the
inter on the dark web and then so you
think some like obviously all different
characters I think it's a completely
different character the same exact setup
of screen recording one screen yeah the
way how like I haven't seen searching
but I've seen missing and then people
explain searching to me so the way how
subm missing evoled from searching I
imagine it's kind of like the same
situation here like similar style but
like what's the with
punched Humphrey Cho
yeah joxy
uhy bro searching is the one with him
yeah when I was filming a movie we
played that on set once so it's the only
time I saw any of it it seemed cool but
I didn't get to see the whole you hav
actually seen it no and then I didn't
see the other one oh missing is great so
I didn't see that only seen missing
whichever one that he is in is the one
that I've seen part of and then I
haven't seen the other oh okay but I
remember looking over being like Oh
that's interesting no dude you should
watch missing then search I mean I've
heard searching is amazing oh one thing
we haven't really talked about is like
how clever this movie is directed and
edited so like what do you even think a
director did on
this what do you mean like what I I I
just don't even know how you what you
think like how did he direct this you
know it's like an improvised script he's
obviously not like is he in there with
each of the actors as they're filming
their part is he like just overse you
know it's kind of like how you know
being an animated director is so
different than being a live action
director this probably is more similar
to being an animated director um which
just like what do you even think that
looked like well I mean you get what I'm
asking kind of yeah yeah uh that is a f
fting question I mean you still I still
feel like you have to storyboard it in
some capacity cuz if you just can't just
get the complete cart blanch to like you
can you could improvise with the
dialogue and I bet there's I don't I
can't imagine it was all strictly one
take like there's too much timing for
sure like his pre-production I can kind
of understand but like on set what is he
is and I imagine where a lot of their
editing might have been able to go down
a little bit more was when they would
actually
uh you know when they're like doing the
messages and then they would Fade Out
the audio of everyone on the Skype I
think that's where they could have some
more like hidden cuts to mask some stuff
to trim it because there's like because
you got to factor in the timing for that
like so much of this is about is about
the timing and then also going through
the performances and stuff and there
there's a lot of ways where I could see
how like there's also got to be the
rehearsal time I would almost think the
director would have to be the editor was
he
not sorry will you look that up for me
can you look that up for me Greg yeah
you know what I mean like when
something's so in your head or the
writer I feel like the writer the
director and the editor all had to be
the same person or they're all in the
room the whole effing time they're not
they're not uhuh
wow is this the same movie yeah that's
her
face what's this skydiving moment what
skydiving moment I know in the trailer
oh I don't
see okay leavon what was his name edited
by Parker and Andrew
Westman he has completely different
directors I mean editors from the
directors wow that would be so
difficult damn that was really cool
really smartly done you you ever watch a
movie Greg and you're like this is such
a what's stopping us yeah you're just
like why didn't I do that yeah it's just
like why didn't I do that
and this came pre pandemic and you have
to really yeah I know it feels like I I
did actually ask myself like did this
come out pandemic but then I remember
the year such a pandemic movie um but
the oh Andrew Westman worked on Five
Nights at Freddy's that's cool uh the
the oh my gosh what what what a
date what a we what a like the the ah
director's editing
remember who you are who you
are something about I mean the editing
is brilliant and and if I just start
spitballing from random compliments
editing brilliant uh sound the sound
design is great
too like you have you have to keep the
audience's attention span for something
that is essentially feeling like it's
one take and one shot which can be a
challenge you know there's some movies
that I've done it where sometimes if you
just set it in one location that can be
boring for people but what's cool is
like there's such a there's such a mixup
of the visuals where it's a lot of times
if you're shooting in one location like
let's say you're just like in a house
you're like well let's at least get
these characters to another room let's
put them in another room so that way you
have a mixup or something like that yeah
and the the way they
utilize um like just the direct
messaging on Facebook the messaging
between uh Blair and Adam is the
boyfriend Mitch Mitch is the boyfriend
Adams the the rich dude between Mitch
and Blair the way they utilize those
those feel like you're in another scene
or or another location in a way you know
that that's kind of what I mean is uh so
I think they the way they have they were
able to like weave in and out and then
even go to like the YouTube videos to
make you feel like you're switching
locations when you're actually not yeah
was very clever we felt like the seventh
friend or whatever like that like the
that box you feel like you're kind of
like there in it just super invested so
I don't think that the lack of locations
was annoying cuz it's like how many
times have you been on well I I actually
don't know what your answer to this is
going to be I've been on facetimes with
people for like four hours sometimes
where you're just like super in it and
you're there and like imagine if your
friends were getting picked off one by
one I don't think like the locations are
even it was just it was entertaining top
to bottom really really well done wow
I'm so impressed by this movie I should
have made this movie I did make this
movie that's how I feel my last thought
is I was surprisingly team Laura really
early on even before I knew how horrible
these people
were yeah I was there's just something
like I just had that inkling of I don't
know I'm kind of on your side I want to
see you torture these people for some
reason even though I don't know why
these people are bad yet I I think that
um and correct me if I'm wrong Greg but
I grew up and I think we're the same age
so you grew up too in like years older
than me am I yeah in woman years oh mhm
in egg years um where
the online bullying phase like started
with us did you feel that way yeah that
so I think that this is like for our gen
and younger than us like this is
extremely relatable I don't know if you
were I was obviously [__] tortured
online oh D of course and still to this
day and so I think that's why you
connected like our team Laura
immediately because it's like here's
what we know from jump they said off
yourself and she did yeah and it's like
you know it I think it's an extremely
relatable emotion when you are getting
tortured by strangers Anonymous people
people without the icon that we saw and
your friends it's it's torturous and
truly so I was on her side from jump too
even though obviously what she did is
messed up you can't just go and I don't
know do that but like I would love to be
a vengeful Spirit against all them
negative comments all the people who are
like Roxy ask too many questions would
don't you just love to go after them Ro
not those people I want to go
after those are not the ones I mean you
got you you you got thicker skin than me
when it comes to the comments game I
hope to be Casper the Friendly Ghost if
I come back Laura was not Casper how
boring oh my God i' want to like
annihilate people you wouldn't want to
reap Revenge
no that's boring man I would want to
haunt you through my television you were
the first person in life to ever call me
boring my dude I said that's boring not
your boring my ghost version of me is
boring I want to be peaceful your ghost
is too nice man would you watch a sequel
to this yeah i' make it about the dark
web no I'm just saying would you be
excited for that like this was good
enough that you would be invested in
another one if it was the same team yeah
man me too why not I mean I'd like to
see them up it like I said I haven't
seen searching and I didn't I didn't
know missing was a sequel until I
watched until after but yeah I didn't
know either you texted me about this and
I said is that the sequel to searching
and you were like no and I said oh okay
then I haven't seen yeah um but the
but damn it Ro what is wrong with my
brain today it's okay we're going to get
out of here anyway do it do it you got
[__] to do is there anybody we want to
say that we love
no just um okay everybody in general
just you know don't cyber bully people
then be nice you're all our friends
don't unfriend unless you're getting
Cyber Bullied and then unfriend oh my
God have you ever been unfriended or
unfollowed by someone when you're like
why they do that it's painful do you
know the kind of week I've had but but
that's different you've had
like I'm saying my friends all
unfriending me yeah yeah your friends my
friends greig really I got to show you
you called them they were your friend
like actual friends I will show you some
things that you will not believe damn
dude that's messed up but yes my answer
your question is yes but you never had
like before this week like like
mysterious unfriending or you're like
what the hell why this person unfollowed
totally you want to know who the first
one
was who constantly no COI Koy constantly
unfriends me and then friend again and
then unfollows and then follows again
every time he starts dating I don't I
don't know my my homie no Cory's my
homie but I've called him out for it a
thousand times he just half the time
unfriends me I have no idea what that's
about ask Cory that's trueth I wonder if
it is no no I don't think so I think
what I've gathered is I don't think he
likes to follow more than 300 people at
a time and sometimes I that weirdly
sounds accurate weird
weirdly sounds accurate but over our
decade friendship I'm going say he's
unfriended and friended me about 40
times so that's that's the truth so much
love to you koi sorry for calling you
out buddy sorry not Sor uh so yeah have
you been unfriended yeah oh man it
happens a lot dude yeah me too all right
that's the show thanks for coming we
made ourselves look
great people in our personal lives
unfriend us all the time it it happen I
I've unfriended a few of them so yeah
I've had it happen a few times yeah I've
done it yeah uh like comment subscribe
and Friend and Friend to friend requests
us so we can use them now okay
[Music]
later